Philip Winkler is a shooting star in
Germany's literary scene his novel pool
has been a surprise sensation it centers
on the hooligan scene of his hometown
football club Hannover 96 the book has
been lauded by both the public and the
critics since the novel debuted a month
ago benkler has been rushing from one
reading and interview to the next the
pool has even been shortlisted for the
German book prize can a writer who's
been living on welfare for the past year
make it in established literary circles
since the marketing campaign for who
will kicked off Phillip Winkler has had
very little time to himself benkler drew
inspiration from the fans of his
hometown football club Hannover 96 he
spent two years writing the novel in the
first month after hitting store shelves
it has already sold 25,000 copies so
incredibly successful I never dreamt
this was possible but has radically
changed my life hurts as some things
have changed and I never had to give
interviews before I mean who wants to
interview a job seeker another book
signing Poole tells the story of heiko
who's a brutal fighter the tale is told
in bare-knuckle language and it's full
of us toot observations it provides an
intimate look into the hooligan scene
it's a foreign world to me
but I enjoyed the book because you can
somewhat identify with the protagonist
welcome to the show Philip Winkler glad
you could make it today you'll be
reading from your novel who'll Winkler
gives plenty of interviews during his
reading tour he gets the same question
over and over is the novel based on
personal experience or just well
researched I did extensive research for
the first half year but at that point I
already knew much more than anyone else
who isn't involved in the scene I've
just always been really interested in it
and closely followed what was happening
this is a wouldn't be for [ __ ] up
readings like these are uncharted
territory for winkler the hall is sold
out Winkler's decided to read some tamer
passages without violence he wants to
bring out his characters human side
described feelings and emotions listen
those guys over there ain't clowns
necessarily he points over to the cars
yeah great idea to point they can't
misunderstand that you keep quiet I'll
do the talking now hand me that gun from
the glove box but down low they're not
supposed to see it's odd when you laugh
at your own material people appreciate
Winkler's laid-back persona and once
again his books sell well at the event
afterward he's exhausted but relieved
this is only the beginning with the
readings I've become pretty used to
interviews by now that was good
I think the audience enjoyed it that's
what matters on the next day
Winkler heads to the football stadium to
watch Hannover 96 play FC Union Berlin
what seems like leisure time is actually
work to journalists a company Winkler
when they arrive the changes in his life
become apparent he'll be watching the
match from the VIP section just like
Germany's former Chancellor Gerhard
schröder
the hanover fans pyrotechnics briefly
halt the second half but ultimately
Hanover loses to one
Frankfurt Central Station
another day another challenge talk
Winkler's on his way to the german book
prize award ceremony he hasn't gotten
over his team's defeat last night but he
did enjoy the pyrotechnics
if you were not really going oh sure
that was awesome but the timing was
wrong you could tell the police were
pretty nervous they could sense
something was going to happen I didn't
really take in much of a match with the
journalists accompanying me and all that
so I didn't pay a lot of attention to
the game at least there was some action
in the second half even though the score
wasn't satisfying that's what can you do
madam fotona given her thorough
come on if mom
in an hour's time the 2016 German book
prize will be awarded it's one of the
industry's most prestigious awards is
that everything vinkor is the only
first-time author shortlisted for the
prize his publisher is waiting for him
it's all good and then it's time for the
photographer's is Winkler nervous I
don't have to do anything today I just
have to sit here and eventually get rid
of my chewing gum
time for a group picture with the
shortlisted authors they're all literary
stars they still don't know who will win
the book prize that sounds like a
machine gun the German Book Prize brings
together the who's who of the literary
scene Philip Winkler is one of the few
not wearing a suit because he doesn't
own one
yet again Winkler's book is presented
and praised hula Stiga she stands our
school is the tale of heiko he's an
outsider his dad's an alcoholic
his mum ran off he flunked his high
school finals twice all he has left his
anger and the only thing he thinks he
can do is fight and organize matches
each Pokemon Sanchez and I spit the
mouthguard into my hand my hands sticky
from the blood my face is robbing with
hot pain lights and Schmidt's I look up
to all is it's always off I hope there's
a second round that's why it hasn't been
a novel like this before it's an
intimate looking to a scene that so far
hasn't received any literary attention
Phillip Winkler who's a debutante has
established himself as a figure in
contemporary literature with great
dialogue with tough dialogue with
hard-hitting sentences coming at
breakneck speed
it's full of memorable scenes
in dodging the German book prize 2016
for the novel of the year the German
publishers and Booksellers Association
Awards this prize to Bordeaux kershaw
totokira the distinguished gentlemen of
Germany's literary scene the next day
the press will write that the jury lost
its courage at the last minute that
moment I thought I place my bets wrong I
didn't expect to win myself that's why I
hadn't prepared an acceptance speech or
anything like that
it's a pity for the publishing house we
would have loved to print an extra 40
thousand copies in the next three days
but I'm happy for Phillip Winkler as an
editor you represent the author not just
the publishing house this will help him
develop his career and he can still
outdo himself so it won't present an
obstacle to his further literary career
time for some small talk at the
reception Kershaw has got some advice
for Winkler but next time you've got to
write something different it's crucial
my next book will be totally different
great excellent
okay now head back over to my family all
right
Philip wingler has learned how to take
such advice this day's been a massive
success for him neither sad nor angry
nor disappointed none of that life is
good